my question about Elite circles we
constantly hear this word elite the
elites the rich Elites the global Elites
the elites you know these days in
America everything's so fracturized I'm
on team red I'm a Democrat I'm very
popular very polarized right and one
thing I always say is like I don't care
about the blue I don't care about the
red I follow the green right it's all
about the money follow the money right
oh right I agree with you there yeah
these themes that we're talking about
with J Edgar Hoover back in the 50s and
beyond that JFK into the 80s and Reagan
and Clinton in the 90s up until today
and Trump there seems to be like three
common themes money power and sex and
that just sort of pierces through
everything is that fair to say yeah I'd
agree with that those are major the
major three things probably that are a
Common Thread throughout my book because
my book really starts back in like the
40s and goes up and so yeah I mean
through that those decades that's
that's what makes the world go around as
far as the U.S is concerned in power
because you know a lot of people look at
the politicians and think that's the
power right but who is backing those
politicians and who's backing those
backers and to paraphrase Jay uh Jr or
Tolkien uh who's the banker of those
backers right so there's like always
these different layers of power and
talking about someone like Roy Cohn Roy
Cohn had a system called the favor bank
system
which is what he called it and everyone
he interacted with had an open account
in his favorite bank and you either you
know do deals with him or you go against
him and you get Plus or minuses and you
know you make all these unsavory
alliances especially New York City to
stay in power
um and things like that and Roy conlord
a lot of this just growing up as a very
young boy he was not typical he was very
interested in power and accumulating it
for a very young age
um and he was very close to like very
prominent mob leaked businessmen like
generoso Pope his uh who was uh the
father of one of his best friends
growing up and had this uh he he was
very close to Frank Costello the mobster
and ran one of the biggest cement
companies or concrete companies in New
York obviously very important to real
estate and very close to organized crime
very politically powerful because he ran
uh had a I think a monopoly on the
Italian language newspapers in New York
for Italian immigrants so he basically
controlled that voting block to a
significant degree
and so you know Roy Cohen had sort of an
inside track into how these deals are
made behind closed doors with
businessmen and politicians his father
was a very prominent judge with a
Democratic party and at this point you
know the Democratic party in New York a
lot of that power basis unions and Ma
the mob took over a lot of the unions
very early on in the in the 20s and the
30s and there are even some cases I know
in the book where you know they wanted a
mob backed politician and power they
threatened the life of some guy and then
they just put the mob guy in and this is
back in the 30s if things really changed
I don't necessarily think that it has I
think more mainstream media willingness
to look at those cases has declined
steadily uh with the years because what
kind of journalist wants to take those
kind of risks right especially if you
live in the swamp that you're writing
about Pat let me get your opinion
because this this is mind-blowing to me
I don't know if there's anybody on the
planet
Like Pat that has interviewed
collectively business people political
figures and MOB people like if you put
those three Trifecta together
Pat is I don't I mean venture to say I
don't know if anybody's on your level in
that regard the these you've interviewed
Rudy Giuliani and and kind of how they
compare you know what the mob does and
political figures like when you're
processing others she brought up Frank
Costello uh like when you're hearing
these common themes like how are you
processing all this no I mean listen
it's it's it's a I I can see this
happening because every the easiest way
to get somebody like have to you ever
see somebody that flips like even the
conversation came up with Joe mentioned
we're talking about why did he all of a
sudden go from not supporting to
supporting what happened there what
happened with uh Colonel Powell go from
you know where he was at to all of a
sudden flipping why do some people all
of a sudden dramatically flip which
makes no sense you were loyal 60 years
to this cause then dramatically you go
XYZ did somebody have something on you
is somebody calling and saying take a
look at this picture take a look at this
video take a look at this I'm not
telling you to do this all I'm saying to
you is if you don't there are people
much more powerful than me that are
going to probably leak this to the
public and I don't want your reputation
to be ruined in the face of your kids
and all that other stuff there are very
few people that are willing to say go
ahead do it I don't care go ahead do
very very few people matter of fact I
wanted to say it's
.0001 because these same people that are
driven by power sex and money are also
driven by Legacy and their reputation
and so the moment you risk their legacy
and reputation that's the ultimate
control but what what do you want to
talk about the ultimate slave the
ultimate slave is when somebody has that
kind of dirt on you for the rest of your
life you have to do whatever they tell
you to do at the sacrifice of anything
so it has that happened was the mob
involved for doing this the mob wants to
control and have power over you back in
the days the way they did it they had
many creative ways of doing it I don't
see this not being the case so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and you you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]